A visitor has come to visit
you Visitor I have brought my son with me
Then
excuse me
[Music]
Are you here
Kiyotaka
[Music]
Reunion after a year and a half?
No, but
one person died because of you. Do
you remember Matsuo, the butler?
He told you about the existence of this school and
helped him escape from me.
The
only son left behind
must be lost in the street by now.
This is the result of breaking my order and entering this school without permission.
You wouldn't even think that you would feel guilty
[music]
Kiyotaka, what on earth made you decide to enter this school?
I wanted to learn about the secular world There is nothing in this world that is better than the path I prepared for you You
decide your own path